the gyro can experience what was the
long as you went before this nine-month
stretch it feels like the last time I
had nine months clean I was nine months
old
no I okay you know in the late nineties
I came out of LA County Jail
my well again the first time I got
arrested for I got arrested for
attempted bank robbery when I was 17
years old I wrote a back tell her a joke
no that said I have a gun and I went to
jail and I got a probation
I asked Estella for $50,000 and and she
started to give me the money and she
puts you she hit the silent alarm I was
with my girlfriend at the time I was 17
she was 18 so a SWAT team showed up to
our house we just left and what do you
have the money I I didn't take the money
tonight if she started to give me the
money but again this is my [ __ ] up
personality for her I I was at Wow I'm
gonna get 50 G's you know and she
started to give it to me but then
something said I can't do this I took
the note I gave her and I crumbled him I
said I'm just kidding and I threw it in
a garbage can I get in my girlfriend's
car and she drives away she goes what
happened I didn't tell her I go out now
that's not it's [ __ ] they had her
name cuz she got an account she's an
adult
oh geez and a SWAT team shows up in her
house so we both get arrested were
handcuffed and I go to jail she I say
and her old man I think was connected it
was like a mob guy and he sat me down
and he goes when you rob a bank you know
take my daughter he didn't I would
probably Robin divided he had a problem
that I took his daughter
you don't think women when you rob a
bank you and I go I wasn't trying to rob
a bank goes night he goes I know you get
a crazed you're cray anyways but but
again I just loved the the the action
yeah that's why I love gambling so um I
go out to LA I get me a TV now I'm
making 10 grand a week
and then I got a bad cocaine problem and
I started gambling the first Tyson
Holyfield fight
I lost $25,000 I thought Tyson was gonna
[ __ ] kill him and Quincy Jones who
produced MADtv got us ringside seats at
the Attic at the fight
and I lose 25 grand on a fight another
eight grand at the tables I get blow I
take it on a plane back to LA at one
o'clock in the morning I take a swing at
a cop and I go to LA County Jail for
trying to assault the cop and he found
that eight ball okay so I had an eight
ball of coke on me I take a swing at a
cop and that's my last day I'd made a DV
oh Jesus I will use this this is 1996
right after we did that sketch of mithya
which is like 95 I think that was 96 it
was 96 a second okay
which is funny to watch because it's so
[ __ ] long ago it's about about a
month after that we did we tape that
sketch I got arrested Wow and so I go to
LA County I come out LA County I'm on
probation and I got to take urine test
everything so I got clean so to answer
your question I had almost a year clean
at that point and then after that it was
off to the races again I so nine months
is the second longest I've had clean
since I'm 11 years old
[Applause]